hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to some
more alpha male
strategies this video is titled why you
have to test women
and how older men can date younger women
yay i'm so excited for this one
um before i start um do not forget to
like comment
and subscribe i also wanted to answer a
question that i've been getting
everyone keeps asking me like in the
comments like why do you only react to
like black creators
like what like why and honestly like
i'm open to reacting to any creator
but the most requested ones happen to be
black but
like i i don't discriminate guys
but i i look for fire content
for content it's going to make me a
little uncomfortable
because that seems to be what you guys
like okay
alpha male strategies let's go
oh what's up fellas all right guys
so today we're here to talk about why
it's important to [ __ ] test women
all right and here's the thing guys this
is f this is advanced
game all right i don't want no guy that
ain't had no ass
in six months you know asking me about
this scratch this is not for you
this is for guys who have rotations and
advanced
games and i want to start making sure
that i have some advanced game
because i know a lot of you guys been
following me a long time and so a lot of
you guys have rotations
and what i'm trying to do is i want to
make sure you keep them alright
i look at rotation guys just like
business
you don't want to be constantly having
to get new clients
and once you got like a set rotation and
[ __ ] like this other than girls
misbehaving and [ __ ] like that and you
tossing ass to the side of the road
if you got a fire girl rotation and they
cool and they know you dating other
women you want to keep them
[ __ ] all right that's why i
want to make sure i
you know be doing things that help you
guys keep these rotation ain't nobody
got time to be constantly
trying to build up a [ __ ] rotation
all right so if you got three four five
six girls whatever the case may be in
your rotation
my job is at this point i want to start
trying to help you guys
maintain that [ __ ] now we all know women
do they [ __ ] and you can't
account for women acting up or whatever
and you have to toss the ass to the side
of the road
which is how you get them to okay i have
two
two questions are stds ever
ever an issue if you're
hooking up with five girls at once
okay the first question second question
i just want to know if the girls in his
rotation watch these videos
that is a reaction that i would pay to
see on youtube
i would i would do the only fan
subscription
to watch like the dating coaches telling
like
these guys how to get women and
they're like women reacting that would
be funny submit all right so make sure
you guys keep doing that do not keep no
[ __ ] masculine ass [ __ ] in your
rotation
just so you can have a rotation all
right when they start doing that
kick the ass out let them come back and
back if they don't bear back to hell
with them
all right so the first thing i want to
talk about guys is
why we got the advanced guys have to
[ __ ] test
guys you have to [ __ ] test because you
want
women that are comfortable with you
dating
other women all right you don't want no
woman that's putting pressure on you
from the get
go about a relationship ain't nothing
wrong with a woman wanting a
relationship
you want to stay away from women who are
looking for a [ __ ] relationship
all right ain't nothing wrong with a
woman wanting uh i want you in a
relationship
that's cool i get that but you want a
woman that has the mindset of hey
you know whenever the right guy comes
along but you don't want a woman that
goes into
every [ __ ] date or every guy she's
[ __ ] with as a potential husband you
want to weed those needy
[ __ ] out now i told you guys
neat i feel attacked
i feel attacked i call these women high
interest women
which is true but here's the thing guys
you want
women that can control their high
interest all right and i'll give y'all
guys a good example
okay don't you guys go out and date
women that you have high interest in
don't you have women that you would like
to pursue like a little bit faster or
won't like man
i would love to have a relationship with
her but you [ __ ] control it all right
because you know it's gonna run her off
well the same thing goes for us guys we
don't need no
uh women in our listen i get you got
high interest
but i don't need no woman that's trying
to push up on me too [ __ ] soon
so i get you got high interest that's
nice and dandy but i don't need you
[ __ ] just blowing me up
all day every day all right you can show
high interest you can initiate contact
cool but i still don't need you hitting
me up 10 times a day
there's a balance to everything all
right high interest means she initiates
you
that don't mean she blow you up all
[ __ ] day all right
that's the thing with that guys so what
we testing for guys
we just want to make sure that women can
control their high interest
all right and we want to weed out the
women
i think i would be one of the needy
girls i'm not even gonna lie
it's like oh this is funny
that are looking for relationships all
right guys
so that's the main thing you know women
test for confidence and [ __ ] like that
we testing because we test to see if
women can control their high interest
all right so that's the thing with that
guys make sure that you do these [ __ ]
[ __ ] tests very imperative and i'll tell
you guys
why [ __ ] tests oh my gosh
let's say hypothetically say you got
girls in your rotation and [ __ ] like
this hill
you don't want some girl throwing in
your [ __ ] face every time you [ __ ]
turn around
oh so you're gonna be with your other
girls this weekend huh
that's the [ __ ] that they say guys all
right when you deal with women like that
who are looking for a relationship or
guys who are not women who are not
understanding that you're dealing with
other women
as a girl is that a situation you want
to be in
i would understand like oblivious to but
like wanna be in
they know they always throw these little
shots in and [ __ ] like that
whenever you take a little trip or who
you taking on the trip with you
all right so that's the thing with that
guys you want to stay away from women
like this you want to stay
you want to deal with women that know
that you like to take your time and they
can respect that
all right now how do you should test
them anything guys
that's you know presupposes that you
have
low interest all right so if you want to
[ __ ] test a woman
all you got to do is act like you have
low interest
all right that's all you have to [ __ ]
do all right the women
that are not looking for relationships
and [ __ ] like this right here
they'll be able to withstand it i tell
you what you call a woman
that's looking for a relationship or
something like that guys
a week later and i tell you right now
she won't answer the [ __ ] phone a
woman who just casually dating guys
i am telling you right now you can hit
up two weeks three weeks
it don't matter she she don't i got you
she don't look at you
that's not bad advice like if you want a
rotation to like
look for girls that want the same thing
all right guys so she it don't matter
when you do a woman that
looking for a relationship or something
like that you'll see it rubs her the
[ __ ] wrong way because you carrying
yourself like you have [ __ ] low
interest
all right now here's the thing if she
initiated contact and [ __ ] like that
radel
what i told you guys how to handle these
girls and stuff like that
but at some point you're gonna back off
all right because what i told you guys
if you're dealing with a woman that has
high interest if you
keep on reciprocating the high energy
what's gonna happen she gonna pull back
funny how that [ __ ] work all right so
you can reciprocate it
to you know to a premium you can't just
keep
doing it so let's hypothetically say she
reach out to you okay you know good
morning hey how your day going you
waited 3-4 hours for the initial
response back then she takes right back
then you waited 15 minutes to text her
back again
then she takes you again now it's time
for you to pull back a little bit
do guys do this they like
track how long right because if you keep
going
now her interest is gonna start to drop
because now you're seeming too available
all right so it's a balance to it all
right
there's a difference between available
and needy
oh hold on it's the music oh my god
there's a difference sorry guys my
oh my god okay the speaker system in my
house is like wild
okay sorry guys i forgot what i was
talking about so all
one minute you got this girl who has
high interest and you like okay ms said
balance it
but then now you're starting to seem too
available and then now she starts to
pull back
all right so that's the thing with that
guys it's a balance to the [ __ ] you want
a response
she's got high interest and even the
next day you can initiate contact
but but there are some guys that win you
over because they're just like
so nice like my boyfriend now that was
why i like liked him was because he was
just so nice
let's hypothetically say the next day
you initiate contact and she hit you
right back
wait 15 20 minutes and you hit her back
and then she keep going
now you got to pull back all right
because now you're going to start to
seem too [ __ ] available all right
so it's always a balance to this [ __ ]
all right
that's the thing with that guys but you
want to make sure that once you got a
rotation
all right once you got a rotation you
have to [ __ ]
test women don't worry about trying to
do this guys if you have one [ __ ]
girl
i probably wouldn't even say worry about
doing this if you have two [ __ ] girls
but if you're a guy who's dealing with
five women or something like that right
there
you ain't gonna be able to see that
woman all the time and let's
hypothetically say
okay she does have high interest but
let's hypothetically say you're a guy
with four five girl rotation
all right and let's hypothetically say
it's wednesday night and that's
hypothetical say you with your
wednesday chick and she hits you up good
evening how was your day
you see what i'm saying you want to have
a woman that's cool with you taking your
time maybe you can't even hit her back
to the next day
because you with your chick or something
like that or your when's the chick
that's not bad advice like i don't
i wouldn't recommend this like that's
obviously not good for your soul
to hook up with five girls in the same
week but
and plus how much time you guys got
but like if you're that type of guy
like find a girl that's cool with it i'd
agree so you might can't even hit her
back to the next day
you want women that are cool with that
that understand what maybe he probably
would have known a girl or something
like that
and the same thing goes for you guys all
right
sometimes you guys will hit a woman up
text a woman and she won't respond to it
till the next day
all right she's probably she obviously
would another dude
all right that's just the way it is all
right she could have been playing a game
but she probably was with another dude
all right and if you act needy and [ __ ]
like this or get upset or get butt hurt
because she took so much you think she
wants you in her rotation
all right so guys it goes both [ __ ]
ways all right
everybody if once y'all guys get to a
rotation
you will see why women get turned off by
needy dudes
all right this only applies to guys who
have rotations
because women always have a rotation
right
here every woman that you're dating
right now
that's at least a seven and above i
guarantee you is dealing with three or
four dudes right now i
damn i was gonna say
i like i three or four at the same time
damn i feel attacked it's cool though
it is what it is it is what it is
[ __ ] to you
all right so anything that comes across
as needed to you
start to bust her groove because she
can't be all the [ __ ] that she want to
be
all right so she try to weave your ass
out there because you don't understand
that she got to be all the [ __ ] she can
be
all right so that's why you turn them
off when you do [ __ ] like that
i found that most girls want
relationships they don't
want like if they're messing with
multiple people it's not because they
want to
it's because haven't found someone they
want a relationship with
when you over pursuing [ __ ] like that
because now you prevent her from being
all the [ __ ] that she can be
all right the same thing goes for us
when you're dealing with a woman and you
got your rotation and [ __ ] like that
and she all up in your ass like that she
preventing you from being a good [ __ ]
all right so that's imperative that you
guys [ __ ] testy women
and guys be quite frank with you if you
see that after you [ __ ] them a couple
times you probably want to get rid of
them because from
my experience it never stops all right
they always throwing little shots they
always got these little sniper marks and
[ __ ] like that
you kind of want to weed them out they
ain't never gonna be cool with you
dating the women the amount of women you
dating
all right so please remember guys this
is
advanced game this is for guys that got
at least four women
if maybe three but i would say at least
four women is he gonna say anything
he repeats himself a lot something like
that right though
all right so obviously this girl i'm not
gonna see that often maybe i see it once
a month or something like that
this is the type of girl that you have
to come saturday and sunday
so what that mean any of the girls that
hit me up that weekend
i'm dead all right i'm dead and i
wouldn't lose no [ __ ] sleep about
it and what you would want is you would
want women that are cool that they
probably figure
he probably had another chick over and
[ __ ] like that you want women as
good that's good hot people
like worlds are so different they're so
different
than like the world of regular people
i would never assume a guy has five
chicks at the same time
like maybe like dming them but hooking
up
with them oh my goodness
dealing with other women you don't want
a woman that's trying to make you be
something that you don't want to be
at this very moment all right so you
need to weed their ass
out all right just respond you know when
you meet them
don't ask them out for a week or
something like that see how they handle
it all right
even if they showed you high interest
you can respond but don't ask out all
right or say you could initiate contact
but don't ask her out
see how cool she is with it all right
see if she get butt hurt about it all
right
you want to weed the [ __ ] out
all right they ain't gonna be nothing
but a pain in the [ __ ] ass
all right and on my next uh
subject my one of my dudes asked me how
can an older dude
date younger women well here's the thing
with this guys
be rich i mean
i was never the type of girl i swear i
remember being like 21 okay
going on dates with a guy who's like 31
and i thought it was so weird
i was like he has a full-time job i'm
just in school like we're in totally
different
places of our lives i couldn't get over
it like i ended it
and
so i was never into like the old thing
like it weirded me out i always
like five years and even when i was like
19
i remember thinking like 21 was too old
or 22
too old but from what i've seen
on like the internet world be rich
here's the thing with this if you're
older guy
the situation is this right here you
never want to make her feel
like she's with her dad all right that
is
the biggest thing all right and the
biggest thing
with that gonna be a lot of the time
guys i don't want to barf a little bit
style all right like i'm
38 if i'm with a woman that's 22
all right i ain't gonna go in and put on
some khakis with that grandpa gray
sweat on or something like i'm older now
so i dress more conservative
but if i'm with a younger chick i'mma
put on some jeans
or polo shirt or something like that i
do dress more conservative
but you never want a chick to feel like
she's with her grandpa all right
and before i say that go any further
please believe this don't mean you gonna
put on some [ __ ]
jerseys with a [ __ ] hat turned around
to the back that's not what the [ __ ] i
said
everything is with balance guys all
right so i don't want to dress like
grandpa
but i don't want to dress like pookie
and ray ray either all right
i want to dress like a nice conservative
guy jeans a polo shirt or something like
that
but i don't want to be dressing like
grandpa with the grandpa sweat on
and [ __ ] khaki pants and all this
other [ __ ] she's gonna start to feel
like she with her [ __ ]
her [ __ ] dad all right so that's from
my i would have just felt like that
anyway my experience got that's been the
biggest thing
with younger younger women is the style
don't dress like grandpa
and for you younger guys this is going
to be pretty much for guys
my age or older all right the next thing
guys is
you can't be acting like an old man what
do i mean like an old man all right
it's saturday night you don't have a
long week and you want this girl to lay
in the bed
and cuddle with your ass oh y'all still
this is a young
girl she want to go out and shake her
[ __ ] ass
all right so if you 38 39 40 years old i
know you
your club days are probably old with i
understand that you dating a younger
chick
that she's still in that stage all right
if she 21 22 23
you was in that phase that's where she
in right now
that's so true when i was it's weird
when i turned 21 that was when i stopped
going to the bars and like drinking and
stuff
but it was before so don't expect a girl
that's 21 22 23
to sit in the house with your old ass
all right she want to get out and shake
her ass
i can see that that's true like
when you're that age you want someone
that's on your same like
party level almost right so if you're
older guy
and you got a young girl you need to
make sure you're out she's gonna
probably love the club and [ __ ] like
that right there all right
i'm just letting you [ __ ] know all
right if you
live this boring ass lifestyle to where
you like a homebody
unless she's already like that but most
21 22 year old
let's be honest they not like that all
right none of us are all us to live our
life
do i need to go to the club now every
[ __ ] weekend hell [ __ ] no
but when i was 21 22 i was in the
[ __ ] club every [ __ ] weekend
every [ __ ] weekend all right so if
you like younger women you need to know
they need to get out and shake their
[ __ ] ass all right
the next thing you need to do go back to
acting like a [ __ ] dad again
talking about her future and all this
other [ __ ] like
trying to mold her and to plan for the
future
man that girl don't want nobody planning
her future why you
why do you think she rebels from her
parents and [ __ ] like that all right
so you just be the life of the party you
just have fun don't be talking about
well you need with them if they give you
choosing signals
if you just randomly go okay i think i
get the idea
you know what this guy is like a
douchebag a little bit
a little bit little douchey but but he's
like
morally like a douchebag i don't know
how to describe it
he chooses to go for like he tells
the people that follow him to go for
women that
want like the same thing as him and like
his followers
so that's not necessarily bad advice um
again
at what cost like will that make you
happy in the long run
you know questions that i can't answer
for you but you know if that's what you
want to do
anyways let me know in the comments if
you liked this video and what video i
should react to
next don't forget to like comment and
subscribe i'm trying to get to 15 000
subscribers by mother's day i don't know
if i can do it
i need a thousand but you know it is
what it is
but subscribe